so the caravel conjecture is what they
believe to be a promising and an
exciting approach for walking for hoping
that closer bounce and my main goal in
this talk is to doll your interest with
this conjecture and invite you to join
us in proving it so I'll focus less on
the details of particular results more
on a broad overview of trade what is
known and what has some nice open
problems we could do open most
specifically the top will have four
parts first in introduction I will just
tell you what it is all about then I
will discuss what is known about this
conjecture then just to give you a
flavor of what is going on and discuss
one proof strategy that has been useful
in moving some of those results and then
finally I'll discard by some future
directions which I believe are good for
proving this result so let's a set of
the scene we are interested in proving
that complexity lower bounds so given a
function f it's that complexity is the
depth of the shallowest circuit that
computes as and here we talked about the
moment circuits that is gay circuits
that have and or and not gates and the
death of the circuit is just the length
of the longest path from an input gate
to the output gate and in a sense it
measures the running time of a parallel
algorithm another important convention
to keep in mind is that we consider only
circuits that have been into that is
every gate has only two incoming wires
now one of the major frontiers of
circuit complexity and complexity of in
general is to come up with an explicit
function f that has the super
logarithmic dead complexity this is also
known as the P vs. NC one question and
in a sense it's a question about the
relative power of parallel algorithms
versus sequential algorithms so we have
this second question and now let's say
so how do we approach it well once porch
were suggested by coachman has Invictus
Zone in 91 and they suggested that we
should try to understand composition so
now I'm going to find the composition of
boolean functions this is probably the
most important definition of this talk
so if you are thinking you're falling
asleep I suggest you do it on the next
slide if we say we have two boolean
functions F from M beats to end one beat
G from n bits to one bit the composition
is the composition is a function that
takes an M by n boolean matrix X and
performs the following computation on it
first we know that the rows of the
matrix are just strings of length n so
they are illegally input for gene so we
compute G on the holes and now we get a
string a which is a string of length M
so it's a legally input for F so we
compute F on this string and we get and
the value we get is the output of the
composed function any question about
this definition okay good so now that we
have defined the composition of three
boolean functions a natural question is
how does that complexity behave with
respect to this composition operation
and one and it is not how to see that
the depth complexity of the compose
function is at most the sum of the dead
complexity of F plus the depth
complexity of G and this is just because
if I compute the composition exactly in
the way I just described I'll get a
circuit whose depth is this much now in
that paper Kosmas and videos couch
mirrors and videos on conjecture that
the complexity of the composition is
roughly that is roughly the sum of the
dead complexities of F and G in other
words this simple way of computing the
composition is roughly the optimal way
and this is a very natural conjecture
it's very interesting in its own right
but they also noticed that if this
conjecture was - then that would imply
the
peas different than nc1 so this
congestion if poured would resolve this
segrand
major frontier that we have in
complexity theory so we are very much
interested in proving it now some of you
might be bothered by this approximate
equality here which makes the statement
of the conjecture a pretty vague so I
prefer to leave it very good because
there are many variants of the
conjecture that would live that would
imply P is different than NC one so
there is no real point in committing to
one particular statement but let's say
that may vary there are quite a few
natural state and variants of that that
would be good for us ok so this is the
conjecture we really want to prove it we
don't know how to do it let's see what
we do know and in order to explain the
known results I first need to in to
explain framework called the cosmic
villains from relations framework which
is the main framework we use to study
this conjecture and what this framework
does is to relate the dead complexity of
function to the communication complexity
of related communication problem this is
the K the communication complexity
techniques that I will refer to earlier
so specifically given a function f we
have this communication complexity
problem communication problem k WS the K
the cultivation relation of Earth or the
K from short the kW relation of F which
is the finest follows and it gets a
string X on which F outputs 0 Bob gets a
string Y on which F outputs 1 and
clearly those are two different strings
so they must differ on at least one
coordinate and the goal of Alice and Bob
is to find at least one such coordinate
on which addition Bob define which x and
y he fell
now the key observation of culture and
with the zone was that the dead
complexity of F equals exactly to the
communication complexity of this
communication problem so this means that
if you want to prove that lower bounds
on
then instead we can pour communication
complexity logo bounce on the catchment
video simulation and this is good
because it gives us a different
perspective on this problem it allows us
to draw on the tools of communication
complexity it's a very nice observation
in general now one technical detail I
should mention is that when I'm talking
about communication complexities
throughout the whole talk I only refer
to deterministic communication
complexity I'll know my spot of course a
completely different story that is
irrelevant to the can W conjecture so
now that we have this framework let's
ask how does the kW conjecture looks in
this framework and the way it looks like
is saying that the communication
complexity of the carry double relation
of the composite function is roughly the
communication complex the sum of the
communication complexities of the kW of
decay double relations of FNG
okay now let's take a deeper more
detailed look on this phrasing of the
conjecture how does the kW relation of
the composed function looks like well
remember that the composed function
takes as input M by n matrix s so an
example now get M by n matrices x and y
and the goal is to find an entry on
which those two matrices differ now what
do they know about these matrices well
they know that if they compute G on
every row of these matrices then they
would get two strings and being such
that if they compute F on those things
they would get 0 and 1 respectively this
is the basic promise that they have and
they want to use it to find an entry on
which the matrices differ now taking
this view there is a natural way to
solve this communication problem so to
see it first note that a and B have a
legal instance of the kW relation of F
so Alice and Bob can use the optimal
strategy for the kW relation of F to
find the coordinate on which a and be
different now
what does it mean that the coordinates
of a and B do well it means that the
corresponding growth of x and y have
different value of G that is G outputs
different values on these walls so this
means these halls are illegally input of
the kW relation of gene so now we can
apply the optimal protocol for the kW
relation regime and find the coordinate
on which these two O's D fell and here
and now we found an an entry on which
those two matrices differ so this shows
the again that the communication
complexity of the kW relation is at most
the sum of the communication
complexities and the kW conjecture can
be viewed as saying that this obvious
protocol is essentially the optimal
protocol from this relation
now okay obviously this is a hard
question
so we're W subject also suggested a
starting point something that would
allow us to get handled on this question
and to that end they defined the what's
called the universal relation and
universal relation is a communication
problem that is a simplification or an
of akw relations what it says is the
following
and it gets a string X Bob gets a string
Y and X and like me any strings now they
don't need to be zero the ones of some
function and the only guarantee is that
x and y are different and now Alice and
Bob want to find a coordinate on which x
and y differ so this is seven some kind
of a simplified version of KW relations
that have no function involved and it is
quite well understood it is not how to
pull that the communication complexity
of this relation is at least n and what
take care W suggested is that we should
try to prove the cal w conjecture for
the composition of two universal
relations first okay so how do we define
even to find this composition well with
the finding in the following way
as before a listen Bob get two matrices
x and y and the whole goal is to find an
entry on which those two matrices D fell
but now they cannot obtain the strings a
and B by computing G on the holes
because there is no function G so
instead we give a and B as additional
inputs to Alice and Bob and now a listen
don't get two promises first is
different than why isn't the same be
second on every coordinate in which a
and B differ the corresponding goals of
x and y also different now the point is
that these two promises are all we need
for the obvious protocol we had before
to go here to see why note that since we
know that a and B are different things
it means that they are legal instances
of the universal relation so this means
we can use an optimal protocol for the
universal relation to find a place where
they differ and now since
[Music]
due to the second promise the
corresponding goals of x and y are also
different so there are also illegal
instance of universal relation and again
we can use the optimal protocol filled
in for the universal relation to find
the coordinate on which they differ so
again the obvious protocol works and
again a natural version of the calendar
block injection would be that this
optimal protocol is roughly optimal and
this challenge was met by Edmonds in
palliate so Hodgins got 91 who proved
the decision in the case up to some
small additive losses and then an
alternative proof was given by Husted
and Victor's own in 93 now going to the
more recent past to get in a joint work
with Dima Gavin's key revenge turn and
average the zone we also proved an
analogue of the Cal W conjecture for the
composition of a function and the
universal relation which is somewhere in
the middle between the composition of
two Universal relations and the
composition of two functions now how do
we define this composition when just
like in the universe the composition of
two universal relations Alice and Bob
get matrixes x and y and since a and b
and they know that whenever a and BD
fell the corresponding goals of x and y
also differ but now they also they are
also given the promise that f outputs 0
1 a and 1 B so they can now so now and
we are actually legally in success of
the kW relation of F and again it can be
shown that the same obvious protocol
from before works and the obvious kW
conjecture would be that this obvious
protocol is optimal and we showed
something like that and gain up to some
additive losses and in a more recent
result we managed to improve these
quantitatively those additive losses and
now they are
very small okay so now we know how to
prove the Cariboo conjecture for the
composition of a function and universal
relation and obviously what we want to
do is to replace this bottom universal
relation with a function with some
function G so in another recent work
together with D mu we pulled ahead the
caravel conjecture when f is when F is
some thick arbitrary function and G is
the parity function of other n bits now
this was actually already known this was
implicit in the work of faster than the
shrinkage exponent but we give an
alternative proof that is more in line
of with the spirit of the works of the
other works on the car Dubuque relation
uses the kW framework and in general we
believe that it has better chances of
generalizing to other functions compared
to the original proof okay so this is
more or less how what we know about the
conjecture so I would now like to
describe one proof strategy that has
been useful for proving some of these
results starting from the work of
multiparous origins girl from 91 so what
we want to do in when we try to prove
variants of the kW conjecture is to
prove that the obvious protocol Optima
is roughly optimal but why should we
believe that it is roughly optimal in
the first place why intuitively should
it be - well one intuition is that what
is a lot more time to do is to find some
entry on which those matrices differ and
in a sense this is almost the same as
just solving the kW relation of gene on
some pair of fours and in particular if
they want to do that
then they must define the wall on which
the values of G are different on the off
X and the row of y if they can find such
a hole then basically they don't have
any handle on the whole they are working
on
they mean they don't know they are not
using the forms they were given so it
makes sense that if they have any chance
of solving this quickly they must find
the role such that the values of G on
this pair of Falls is different and
saying that the values of gene on duels
is different is just like saying that
the corresponding values of a and B diff
are different because the values of a
and B are just the values of G and is
also the thing is that finding a
coordinator matrix corresponding to all
the values of G is different that is a
and B are different is exactly by
definition solving the kW relation of F
this is what serving the kW relation of
F means so to sum up they want to solve
the kW relation of G on some pair of
Falls and in order to know what purfles
they want to walk on they have to solve
first decade evaluation of F so this is
basically saying that they have to
wonder obvious protocol now this
intuition is somewhat sketchy but
sometimes it can actually be turned into
a proof and indeed sometimes we can
implement this intuition using an
adversary argument and what does that
verse we do well that verse array is
letting Alice and Bob talk in bran and
while they are doing that that virtually
measures the progress they make on each
pair of oars in solving the kW relation
of G now whenever that well Sri sees
that Allison Bob we've made too much
progress on some powerful that very just
kills the bow and makes the progress
before nothing I mean in the way that
was it was that does that is by forcing
the Equality AI equals bi that is it
forces G two outputs the same value on
this pair of Falls and we can show that
if that versa does it then this prevents
a listen doll from solving the kW
relation on these fellows now the thing
is that we can keep doing that as long
as they didn't solve the kW relation of
FBI
as long as they didn't serve the kW
relation of F they don't know any
coordinate on which a and B must be
different so that Wesley has a free hand
in forcing coordinates of a and B to be
equal and since that versa we can do
that the players have no choice but the
first serving F and then solve G and
that's the more or less the only thing
they can do now this is a very
simplistic description it's not so easy
there are lots of technical issues that
need to be overcome but sometimes they
can be overcome
however one specific issue I want to
discuss now is I said that we are going
to measure how much progress that
versary is making on on each pair of
oars in solving - observing the kW
relation of G how do we measure that how
do we measure that progress so where I
don't know if any general solution but
here is a solution that sometimes works
let's say that G has satisfied some nice
assumptions that will allow us to walk
with it so in particular let's say that
when we look at the kind of elevation of
G on its own
now we separately from the KWA sure of
the compose function forget about the
compose function for a moment then this
relation has a lower bound move that is
posed using an adversity argument again
a separate adversity argument from the
adversity argument which we just
discussed the kW elation of G at its own
adversity argument in Mora well let's
assume that this adversely argument
proves the lower bound for the kW action
of G has some a nice measure of progress
that measures how much information so it
measures how much focus the players made
on this pair of Falls sorry on the
internships for kwg and typically this
measure of progress will be indeed the
amount of information that the players
transmitted on their inputs on some
important aspect of parts of their
inputs
so if we have such a nice adversary then
we can use this a nice measure nice
pocket measure the adversary uses back
in that verse early for the back into
the bigger adversary for the composed
function that will say described in the
next slide so that's Bey that's a very
laughs intuition of what we are doing
now again this is very sketchy and I
don't have precise definitions for what
a nice measure is and so on but the
thing is that this is basically the
outline of what is going on in the
proofs for the universe elimination and
the parity relation okw relation we have
some nice information theoretic measure
of what the players are doing and we
embed it into the adversary oh that was
the wrong one for the composed function
now for future reference I would like to
refer to this type for the bursaries
information-theoretic adversaries
because in all the examples I know this
kind of adversaries measure the focus of
the players using some kind of an
information theoretic measure
and these blames and this brings us to
the discussion of where do we go next
from here so in order to prove the k-dub
the kW conjecture we now need to prove
the conjecture for any composition of
two functions F and G for avatar choices
of F and G now our previous works showed
that we more or less know how to deal
with an arbitrary choice of the function
f I'm not so worried about this aspect
however when trying to go on further and
prove the conjecture once is that
actually dealing with this arbitrary
function G is much harder and we don't
even know how to prove the leave else a
version of what we know of a universal
relation composed with G and one reason
for that is that an arbitrary function G
may not have an information theoretic
adversary and even if it it has we don't
know how to find it so I mean it's not
clear how to get past this obstacle but
now let's suppose that we don't want to
prove the full kW conjecture but instead
we only want to prove better lower bound
so you just want to prove the peace
difference and then c1 then there is
some hope that maybe we don't need to
deliver an arbitrary function G maybe we
can find some kind of a complete
function or some complete communication
problem such that if we deal just with
this communication problem then we will
be able then this will already separate
performance e1 and if we have such a
problem we will be very happy we won't
need to deal with an arbitrary function
G and if it also this communication
problem also have an information
theoretic adversary we will be even
happier and we have a candidate for such
a communication problem which is called
the multiplexer elation so I will now
describe this candidate so the
multiplexer relation is basically the kW
relation
of an F function G except that now G is
not fixed arbitrary function but rather
it is part of the input now so not
specifically the communication problem
is defined as follows
Alice gets as an input a function G from
n bits to one bit and something X on
which G outputs zero Bob gets the same
function G and some string on which this
G outputs Juana and now the goal is to
find a coordinate on or which is
different than Y okay so this isn't a
very natural problem communication
problem it is also in a sense of
simplification of KW relations and maybe
you can also see why we think it should
be complete basically it is like the kW
relation of the address function of the
index function accepted we give the
players those de-spawn s that they have
the same function G here which is not
the case in the usual KW relation of the
others function now we we understand
this multiplexer relation relatively
well and in particular we know how to
prove that it's communication complexity
is linear so we don't worry about that
so now that we have this multiplexer
relation let's see how we define the
composition so in the composition of a
function if the multiplexer elation
Ellison Bob again as usual get two
matrices x and y but now they are also
given these M functions for each row G 1
G 2 2 G m and now they obtain these
things a and B by computing
every function G on the corresponding
world and again they get the same
functions it's important that you get
the same functions G 1 2 G M and again
the promise is that F outputs 0 on a and
1 on B so natural analog for the care W
conjecture for that composition would be
that the obvious protocol is optimal
which means that the communication
complexity of this relation is basically
the communication flex t of F plus Omega
n now this is a very interesting
injection it's alright if for start it
is implied by the kW conjecture so if we
have to put the card away from the
conjecture we should be able for start
to prove this conjecture now although we
have some evidence that suggests that if
this conjecture is true then this would
actually already implied it P is a
difference on NC 1 we don't know it for
sure but it seems very likely ok so me
so this sounds like a good the
conjecture to go for and in fact I would
like to mention that maybe even for
start it would be interesting to look at
the composition of the universal
relation with multiplex so in which we
don't we are not guaranteed that some
function f output 0 and again one won't
be but just that a and B are different
and then we have a very nice and clean
communication problem that has no
arbitrary functions involved so maybe we
can prove a lower bound on that now
another very nice property of this
multiplexer relation is that it does
have an information theoretic adversary
so this gives hope that maybe we have a
plan for separating p form and c1 we
first incorporate this information
theoretic adversary inside the poof
strategy that i described in the
previous part and we use this poof
strategy to prove the Cariboo conjecture
for the composition i just described in
the previous slide
and then we used the poor disproof to
separate performanc one now this is a
nice plan
personally I think it is a good plan we
should try to carry it out but obviously
I don't know how to carry it out if I
did they would give very different talk
today so why can't we carry it out of
why is it not easy well basically it's
because that value of the multiplex the
relation is very complicated and also
very and robust very simpler changes
makes it go on and then and this makes
it very hard to incorporate this
adversary in the poof strategy I
described before so we don't really know
how to do that so how can so well can we
go from here you know well my feeling is
that the good direction to go from here
is to try to develop our techniques and
extend them further such that they can
handle more and more sophisticated
information theoretic adversaries until
they finally start they are finally
strong enough to deal with the
information to adversity of the
multiplexer relation now how can we
develop our techniques further well my
suggestion is that we first tried to
prove composition results by
implementing that proof such as I
described with adversary with
information theoretic adversaries that
are easier than the one of the multiplex
simulation simpler than the one of the
multiplexer relation but still are more
interesting in the compositional results
we know for the universal relation and
the parity relation and there are
several nice communication problems with
such information theoretic adversaries
so I suggest we try to prove in a
composition results for them so here are
some candidates I have in mind the
greatness tips of folk relation the
monotonicity connectivity relation the
monotonic relation I won't have time to
describe them but they are very simple
problems that are very nice and clean
adversaries that you can find in
textbooks such as the textbook of hakuna
of crucial evidence and
so can we pull composition results for
those delusions or maybe even just
composition results with the universal
relation I think these are very good
nice and clean and hopefully talked
about open problems that we can work on
so let me wrap up
so the Cal W conjecture is a promising
approach for proving the trees different
than NC one we know how to prove it when
the inner function is the universal
relation or the parity relay or the
political W relation and a possible
approach to go further is to prove it
for an inner function is the multiplexer
relation and some complete open problems
that I think are good would be to prove
the car w conjecture when the inner
function is default collation there's
the connectivity relation or the clique
relation thank you very much
[Applause]
so that's another great question - we
don't even know how to put the countable
you conjecture in the monofin case no
not in general we know how to do it for
very specific functions which is what
klw did in the original paper but we
don't have any general proof of the card
and Luke injection for monotone nerve
functions yeah so their natural proofs
barrier does not apply to the supports
because this approach only proves
allowable for a very specific function
so it does not have the largest property
of the natural possible yeah thanks
basically what you say is that okay you
start from a random function of log n
bits so this is this has that complexity
about log N and it's explicit because it
can be discard using n bits I'm sweeping
something over the top you know but
basically this it's explicit and then
you composite with itself log in times
and you get that log squared n of
put this thing Oregon
[Applause]